hi thank you I'm excited to be here
today and thank you everyone for coming
out last year I came to I did a
tutorials today day and I really enjoyed
it
so I hope you enjoy your day here at pie
Judah and your entire conference so
today I'm going to be talking about
computer vision with my torch and I'm
gonna start off by talking about like
what computer vision is generally
speaking in computer vision is the
process of extracting patterns from
images and in recent years convolutional
neural networks have gotten much better
at sorry performance on computer vision
tasks has increased dramatically in
recent years with the rise of
convolutional neural networks I'm gonna
talk about PI torch PI torch is a
popular framework for implementing
neural networks
it runs on GPU it's a popular choice for
working with images text and audio data
afterwards I'm gonna go through a few
examples of common tasks in computer
vision including classification object
detection and segmentation notebooks are
available on github so we'll cover this
more when we get to that point in the
presentation but there's a github link
there are both Jupiter notebooks and if
you don't have condor or pi torch
installed there are google collab links
to run code in the browser afterwards
there will be a Q&A session I anticipate
we'll have a lot of time for questions
so feel free to ask away
so what is computer vision computer
vision is an interdisciplinary field
focused on the development of using
algorithms to interpret digital images
and videos so here I have a few common
computer vision tasks so like given an
image what's in it is it a dog is it a
cat is it a person that's classification
object detection focuses on fine
producing bounty boxes of objects like
in this case and so forth you know you
could do cars you could do people that
sort of thing and segmentation produces
a pixel wise mask for objects in an
image these are just a few
computer vision tasks in general
anything you can train a neural network
to do you can do with computer vision
the key idea is the convolutional neural
networks have gotten a lot better in
recent years so feature extraction in
computer vision has gotten a lot better
so here on the right I showed the top
five error rate on the image net
large-scale visual recognition challenge
this is a competition where a large data
set with over a million images where the
goal is to predict the class of a given
image so it might be an airplane or it
might be a fire hydrant that sort of
thing and before 2012 traditional
machine learning methods were used on
imagenet it wasn't until 2012 that
convolutional neural networks were first
used and that red led to a dramatic drop
in the top five error rate currently the
last image net contest was held in 2017
but the benchmark is still maintained
just not in contest for him
and as of 2019 the top five error rate
is down at one point eight percent so
computer vision
come a long way in the last six or seven
years and this is due to a number of
factors first improved algorithms so
convolutional neural network
architectures have gotten better new
architectures are constantly being
released on the order of every few
months that's coupled with improved
Hardware so computer vision is
computationally intensive so and the
algorithms have existed for a while but
the hardware has been improving rapidly
with NVIDIA GPUs that run CUDA and
Google TP use that run algorithms
efficiently along with hardware comes
software support for that hardware
the two biggest software platforms in
computer vision are tensorflow which was
Reduce released by Google in 2015 and pi
torch which was released by Facebook in
2016 and both platforms are being
actively developed in these platforms
essentially our numpy with support for
GPUs and also support for neural network
operations and image data so I'm gonna
I've been talking about convolutional
neural networks I'm gonna talk at a high
level how they work so some image in
this case it's a it's a 32 by 32
character and come like so this image of
course is represented as a matrix or a
tensor so that computers can work with
it
convolutions are applied to the input
image so you know in a case like this
you might map 5x5 pixel region in the
initial image to a one to one by one
region in what's called a feature map
and each convolution has different
weights so and the idea there is that
you can extract different features from
an input image so each of these
future of apps might find like at a high
level might find something like vertical
lines horizontal lines corners which is
great and then there's a sub sampling or
a pooling step where the dimensionality
of these future maps are reduced so you
might do something like look at a 2x2
grid in a feature map and and find the
max value or find the minimum value or
something like that and you can repeat
this process a few times and get and as
you progress deeper into the network you
get features over larger and larger
regions of the image and finally you
might represent the image and then using
traditional methods depending what your
target variable is you can have a
standard fully connected Network this is
covered in more detail elsewhere I have
references in the slides I'd say the
main idea is that convolutional neural
networks are really good at extracting
features from image images and what you
do with those features depends on what
you want to do with the image so I know
here I set some of the common tasks or
classification detecting object
segmentation but you can do things like
predicting distance to object you can do
style transfer you can do a lot of
things but like the common component in
modern computer vision systems is that
convolutional neural networks are used
to extract features another thing that's
been really great especially recently
with PI torch and tensor flow is pre
trained models so training models from
scratch is computationally intensive you
know like the image net data set is over
a million images mostly as models at
millions of weights it's expensive it
can be challenging to get right the
first time so pre trained models are
really helpful so for a classification
for example there are a bunch of pre
train models
imagenet for object detection models are
typically pre trained on cocoa which is
the data set that has 80 different
classes and PI torch comes standard with
the number of pre trained models we'll
go through this in the note book section
but it's really easy to call a pre
trained model from PI torch to detect
objects or to classify an image and any
model that's available in the research
you can find on github somewhere you can
download from PI torch hub so even if a
model is not in the standard PI torch
distribution you can download it from
somewhere and in computer vision because
one property is that this this process
here of extracting features is fairly
general you might be doing things like
looking for vertical lines in an image
or looking for corners and in the future
extraction process tends to transfer
well between tasks so a lot so it's not
it's common in computer vision to start
with the pre trained model either for
initial weights or you can even freeze
the weights and then add additional
classes to a model so a model is trained
to detect dogs you could train it to
detect cats if you have a data set of of
cat images that sort of thing good
and so I've been talking about PI torch
this talk is about PI torch I'm gonna go
into a little bit more detail about what
PI torch is PI torch is a library for
tensor operations it was released by
Facebook in 2016 the style of Pi torch
is fast experimentation it is a Python
first library it's dynamically typed
like Python which is nice it's
essentially numpy with GPU support
there's a lot of integrations with numpy
so you defined tensors you can put
tensors on GPUs and there's a lot of
built-in support for like like data
loaders so to load your data set
training neural networks and there's a
torch vision package which helps with
transforms for images and ok so I'm
gonna switch over to more hands-on on
github so here so I'm going to go
through a few notebooks on the tutorial
github page if you want to follow along
on your laptop feel free you can either
run the notebooks locally if you have
Conda and PI torch installed it takes a
little while to install because there's
a bunch of CUDA libraries so I was
trying to get the latest version of my
laptop last night and it took took a
while also each notebook has a collab
link so if you go to this github page
and you click on a notebook and you
click on this link the notebook will
actually open in the browser I just
discovered a collab a few days ago but
it's a service by Google where you can
run notebooks in the cloud with GPU
support for free a couple couple of
sign-in screens the first time but it's
not too bad and this is really useful
because Google actually has PI torch
pre-installed so the notebook should run
smoothly in collab
okay
and again like this is listed as a
beginner level tutorial so I'm going to
start by going over the very basics and
then I'll provide references to more
intensive like like objective detection
training methods and stuff if you're
interested later okay so this is the
getting started notebook so if you
haven't already if you don't have PI
Church installed you can install it with
Khanda install PI torch - see pi torch
it's recommended to use condo over pip
for installing PI torch you'll get 1.3
the most recent version pip will
probably give you 1.0 PI torch does come
with CUDA libraries so this does take a
while also installed torch vision you
can install that with pip that's easy
and like as I just showed you especially
if you're looking to experiment google
collab is a good option for getting
these notebooks running for running code
cells also if you go to the pipe torch
so the pi torch web page has a lot of
good materials from research to
production if you click on the tutorials
page and you click on you know tutorial
like these tutorials you can run in
google call lab okay
so I guess let's clear out put okay so
I'm going to run this from scratch so
typically you start by importing torch
and torch vision especially torch vision
has a bunch of different libraries so
you might import torch patient
transforms this transforms or something
there are there are number conventions
around that so torch tensors are
essentially numpy rays so here I have a
tensor of zeros and I can do something
like X plus 1 and now I have a tensor of
you know ones and if I say X plus torch
tensor of like torch dot ones three
three or something like this oh okay
times to get ton serve twos so if you
use numpy torches designed to use a lot
of the same api is this numpy there are
a couple differences that we'll get to
later and just another example you can
define a you can create a torch tensor
from a list that sort of thing okay and
torched answers can be converted to and
from non Pyrus so here I have a number R
a three two one and there's a method
from numpy so I can convert this numpy
array into a torch tensor one thing to
note is that there is a data type so
that so this is an in thirty two data
types matter when you're running on GPUs
GPUs are highly paralyzed and every bit
that's allocated to you you know a
number or a integer in a tensor matters
so just be aware of the data type and
sometimes they'll get an error like oh
you you gave a
float but you were supposed to give an
integer sixteen if you care about
datatype most of time you can type D
type and then maybe I can say something
like float doing this from memory that's
by not right
maybe it's float 32 oh no I think it's
okay I think it's a string Oh from numpy
takes no arguments okay well if you do
if you do torch tensor I know it takes
float do you can pass in a data type as
a float or something like that from num
num pi now remember actually uses the
same data button to type this design
it's assigned to num pi so if you have
an umpire array you can specify a data
type as an integer or float and that
will be copied into the PI torch tensor
and again so here if you want to go from
a torch tensor to an umpire right you
can call numpy and you just get a numpy
array okay so one of the big so torch is
very similar to numpy for basic
operations one of the things that is
really useful for computer vision is
support for CUDA so a very common design
pattern in torch scripts is to let me
make this a little bit bigger okay is to
have this torch CUDA is available so a
lot of times you have a script if
someone has a GPU you want it to run on
GPU if someone doesn't have a GPU you
want the script is still run so this is
a really nice design pattern so you say
if CUDA is available use the Kudo device
or the GPU and otherwise set the device
to CPU
I'm gonna back up a little bit and talk
about devices so in numpy it's assumed
that all your data lives on the CPU so
there's no concept of device in torch
there's this concept of device where you
either have data that lives on the CPU
or data that lives on the GPU and for
things to work properly you either want
the all the data and the computation to
be done on CPU or entirely on GPU so
here okay I provide an example of
creating a sensor and setting the device
to CPU if this laptop how to GPU enabled
I think Kolob has sheepy enabled it will
find the cuda device and a little and
here instead of CPU it'll say GPU zero
uh I haven't tested that I know that
there is a way to get GPU and goal of
you can get up to 12 hours for free but
I don't want to I don't want to try and
figure it out during the presentation
but but I know there's a way to do it
okay for working with images the Python
image library is very helpful if you're
on collab just to note collab is for Eid
if you're on collab you need to download
the image from the internet so use this
like W get come in to grab the image if
you clone the repo you you don't need to
do this so python image library supports
loading images easily so here you can
see like I open a JPEG image of a dog
and a bicycle and I show the image and
toward the torch vision package can
easily convert this into a tensor so
here I'm using a torch vision transform
to tensor and I get an image that's
three for the RGB channels and 576 by
768 which is the dimensions of the image
I'll note that in torch vision dot
transforms there's another number of
other operations so if you want to do
pre-processing where maybe you flip the
image by a hundred eighty degrees or you
rotate the image or you do image
augmentation you can compose transforms
together more complicated ones and use
that frame of documentation so there is
one gotcha this is probably the biggest
gotcha that I've run into and torch and
that's if you're working with if you're
feeding data into models there's a
convention that you add extra dimension
at the beginning and that's where the
batch size and that's because it's like
typically it's more efficient to pass in
a big matrix as opposed to a bunch of
small matrix matrices so you might have
a batch size in a typical case of 16 or
32 depending on GPU memory so
even if you're passing in a single image
convention here is to add an extra
dimension for the bachelor size so
there's this unscrews operator that'll
add a dimension and if you want to get
rid of the dimension you can do image
sensor without squeeze and shape and
that will get rid of the dimension so
this is just something to pay attention
to okay and so at this point we have an
image it's loaded into CPU if if you're
using a GPU device you can use a design
pattern like this so for inference with
pre-trained models I'm gonna use the
collab version
okay so pre trained computer vision
models are useful particularly if
particularly if you have a common task
so if you want to do something like
detect a person and image detect a tell
whether an image is a dog or a cat or
maybe like segments an object in an
image common tasks there's a good chance
that there's a pre trained model off the
shelf that you can use for that task if
you have a more custom data set like for
example if you care about maybe
identifying your dog as opposed to dogs
in general you'll likely need to train a
specific model for that task which we'll
cover next
okay so OOP okay so running this in
collab
so going to start with imports
so this will download the image from
github and going to display the image
okay so we have this image tensor so
insert code so so just examining the
image sensor a little bit a bunch of RGB
values and okay so cocoa is a popular
dataset oh did this last night too
computer vision isn't as popular as
Disney although it should be okay so
cocoa is the data set that consists of
common objects and contests
so there's 80 of these so for example
you want to look at dogs see
okay this is a nice Explorer so you can
see okay we have a dog we have a frisbee
[Music]
okay
this image has a dog in a frisbee this
image has a dog in a hairdryer this
image is the dog looking looking out the
window okay a dog in a horse Coco has a
lot of variety and it's and it's free to
use it's open source so for object
detection Coco is the data set that's
most commonly used and so you can see
classes include person bicycle car
motorcycle and now so here I'm using
masks are CNN which is a model that's be
trained for or it's a model architecture
that's good for object detection that's
good for segmentation and running this
in pythor choose just a few lines of
code
so there's torch vision models let's see
so torch vision dot models comes with a
bunch of pre-trained bottles so for
there's some for classification
detection I like masks are seen on a lot
segmentation oh and then there's a few
models for semantic segmentation as well
again these are just models that PI
torch is included in the main libraries
of convenience I find them to be helpful
of course anything that's in the
literature you can find on get like the
researchers will post on github and also
you're welcome to build your own
architectures as well so here one little
there's a pre trained equals true flag
if you want to include free trade model
weights this valve function I haven't
discussed gradients in PI torch in depth
but one difference between pi torch and
numpy is that hi torch actually tracks
gradients of tensors in a graph and I
don't want to go into too much detail
until we get to the training section
section but if Val basically says don't
don't don't record the gradient like
don't don't update the gradient don't
don't worry about gradients just use
this for evaluation as opposed to
training okay so this is the key line so
so we import the model we run prediction
this zero is like so remember how I said
there's a batch size the zero means grab
the first element so it's we're only
passing in one image so it's a batch
size of ones the zero says grab the
first element in the batch one thing to
just be aware of is that there's a batch
size pay attention to that here I add
names like the default return type is a
tensor here I return names so we can
interpret what's in the image so here
the result of running masks are CNN on
this image is we have a bunch of
bounding boxes if I recall correctly
this is xmin xmax wyman WiMAX every
object detection framework has different
conventions on the four numbers that
specify the box so the labels 18 to 2 if
we look at the names of those dog
bicycle bicycle bicycle car truck potted
plant and here if you look at the scores
these are numbers 0 to 1 that specify
how confident the network is in a
prediction so you can see that for dog
it's very confidence score of 99 98 for
bicycle and then it falls off a bit
after that 80 for bicycle 75 75 and then
54 for the
for truck and then below that it's it's
33 or below so in practice a lot of
times you set a threshold and say let's
look at predictions with a confidence
score above 50% or something
those confidence scores depend on tasks
and depend on your training set and test
set so I definitely recommend choosing a
threshold like after examining the
results and so so I looked at these
predictions last night and it predicts
this dog with high confidence it
predicts this bike with high confidence
it gets a little bit confused by this
motorcycle in the corner it has two
different predictions there so it gets a
little bit confused by this and then for
this truck was it a cars at a truck it
thinks it's both it's a little bit
confused there too but you know which is
pretty typical performance for the
things that humans can see easily like
this is obviously a dog this is a bike
this is probably a motorcycle it's a
little bit obscured this is somewhere
between a car and a truck
so I'd say sort of object detection
methods or only is like only as good as
like if there's any human ambiguity in
labeling like maybe some laborers would
label this motorcycle maybe some wooden
if there's ambiguity and late inhuman
labels there might be ambiguity in
predictions as well
okay um see how am i doing on time okay
I want to leave plenty of time for
questions so this is the last notebook
this is some references on training
computer vision models in PI torch this
is significantly more involved than
essentially the two lines of using a
tree trend model and and and as I said
before the key feature of computer
vision is this model architecture so for
extracting features you're going to use
convolutional neural networks a lot of
times it makes sense to use like for
applications it makes sense to use
existing model architectures perhaps
with pre trained model weights as a
starting point a lot of research has
gone into those and they tend to perform
better than defining something from
scratch for complex problems so a common
approach is to use model weights pre
trained on image net and defining the
rest of the network and and written
training the rest of the network or fine
tuning the weights so typical formulas
defining a torch data set and data
loader so in torch you define an object
called typically does define an object
called the dataset on defined data
loaders that dynamically load data from
the data set typically this is a tensor
X representing an image and Y being
whatever label you're trying to predict
determine define model architecture
again here it's useful to look from
existing architectures initialize model
weights loss function will depend on
what target you're looking at so for
something like object so for something
like classification you can use the
standard cross-entropy for
classification for something like object
detection see so so for object detection
or segmentation the loss function isn't
as clear
you know you know I can tell you for our
CNN the loss function looks something
like is there an object in this box is
that object what the class label
predicts and how good are the bounding
and how good is the bounding box
prediction although if you're doing
something like object detection you can
use the standard loss function for for
object detection select an optimizer
same with any neural network
optimization I like to use atom you need
a data set so if you're training you can
either provide your own data set like if
you wanted to build a model that said
like is there a car in this parking spot
you might provide a number of images
with the car in the parking spot a
number of images without a car and train
a model owned out there also a lot of
open source data sets available with
images and labels available and I think
it's important to benchmark the
performance of the model a lot of times
you're going to be doing hyper parameter
tuning you're going to be trying
different maybe different architectures
maybe you won't want to know when to
stop training so it's important to look
at your loss function maybe look at
accuracy and determine how long you want
to train for so PI torch has a number of
tutorials on model training so there's
one on training a simple classifier the
this is a simple two layer model from
scratch I think I'll go over this
briefly there's a object detection fine
tuning tour tutorial this one I found
very useful in practice it is a bit more
involved you need to download a data set
from from the internet you need to like
the download PI cocoa tools and stuff
and so this I like because it gets into
a lot of the nitty-gritty of how do you
process images and and and how do you
get them into it into usable form and
for no neural transfer I include this is
an example of cool things that you can
do with
computer vision so here the ideas that
you have a style image and content image
and you have a loss function that
incorporates matching the content of the
comp content image in the style of the
style image and you can get something
cool like this so feel free to check
that out I think and these are all
available as collab notebooks so if so
feel free to go through them I'm I'm
gonna go through the training classifier
tutorial I'm going to open this in I
think I know that and I'm just gonna
stick it a high level on the website for
now so if you're working with images
again pillow the Python image library is
very useful for loading images OpenCV
open computer vision is also very useful
in in Python that's like if you want to
do simple operations like change the
contrast of an image or flip an image
you can do simple operations like that
with OpenCV again like pi torch also
supports audio and text how if I berries
out of the box so this is the CFR 10
dataset it has different classes like
airplane bird cat dear frog it's it's
small so it's fast a train C far 10 was
more popular sort of sort of in these
days and in 2010 2012 when imagenet was
quite hard
cor 10 was easier because there's only
ten classes instead of a thousand so CFR
10 is good for fast training and it was
a very popular benchmark several years
ago
okay so again train test split to find a
network to find a loss function train
the network and then
benchmark the network on test data so
again import torch torch vision
transforms okay so now when I was
talking about let me zoom in a little
bit okay so this is an example of
pre-processing so torch transforms
allows you to perform a series of
transforms on some sort of image because
typically you have you know maybe some
folder the folder has a bunch of JPEG
images what you want is you want tensors
you want to be able to operate on these
on GPU and you know like sometimes you
need to normalize if you're doing image
augmentation sometimes you want to flip
maybe you want to rotate maybe you want
to randomly crop to get a more robust
training set so transforms dot compose
lets you group multiple transforms
together so here for first we take the
object convert it to a torch tensor and
then we use a normalized function to
standardize the image so the the torch
documentation is quite good okay so I
see okay I'm trying to get a list of
torch transforms but just like as an
example you can do a random affine
transformation you can do a random apply
that sort of thing so it's so really
useful for pre-processing some of these
datasets are free predefined in torch so
if you want to download a bunch of these
see for our ten images all you need to
do is define a dataset see far ten oh
sorry oh okay download equals true so
this will actually download the data set
for you and it'll pre process the images
according to this transform
the data loader
is this is a very useful idea too so
this is actually dynamic data loader so
you might have some data set that's a
bunch of images on disk or in this case
a bunch of images on pipe or servers and
this data loader will actually
dynamically grab images from the train
set as they're needed so if you say ok I
have this data set and I have this data
loader nothing happens and then when you
want to grab when you want to perform
training and you want to grab so like in
this case four images at a time as the
batch size it'll grab four images from
the data set like at runtime and give
those to you so that's a bit different
than tensor flow which is statically
typed and so I think one of the biggest
and pythor Chen tensorflow are both
great libraries very well supported I
think one of the factors that pushes
people one way or the other is do you
want something like tensor flow that
statically typed which is maybe you you
know which well pythons dynamically
typed so if you're using Python
I think dynamic typing is consistent
with a lot of Python like things if
you're working in something like Java
while pi tortures an in Java but Java
statically typed and so you know having
a statically typed library and
statically typed statically types tensor
library makes sense okay and same thing
for Tessa okay
you you can show images using matplotlib
again integrated tightly with numpy okay
and so so that's defining the data set
again you can use some of these standard
data sets there
support for that so this is defining a
neural network so torch has a neural
network library torch NN and a
functional library of functions that you
can apply within neural networks so here
when you define network you define a new
class so this is called net but you
could call this like anything you want
you could call this like you know like
my network or anything you want it
extends the neural network module a
module is either a network or a sub
Network you can have network speed into
networks and you need a constructor
method and the constructor method calls
the constructor of neural map module
typically in the constructor you define
your layers so here there's a
convolutional layer a pooling layer a
convolutional layer and three fully
connected layers so this is a simple
Network the looks a lot like this one
convolution pool fully connected layers
in practice for modern architectures
like resna these get a lot deeper you
might have something like 50 layers you
know a bunch of convolutions and
pullings
nonlinearities like batch norm and relu
are very helpful if you're dealing with
a network that's that deep a lot of
times it makes sense to like grab a
ResNet definition or or something like
that and then maybe tweak it if you need
to but for a shallow network like this
you can do it both ways you can either
load a definition that's essentially a
file that looks like this or you can
write it yourself
and then you define for it and so this
is when you pass an input accent to the
network what happens so in in in this
case you have an input X you apply a
convolution that ok and then you apply
relu ok and then you apply a pooling
function
so here you apply the second convolution
with the weights specified here you
apply Rallo and the new pool view is
kind of a funny thing it it lets you
change the shape of tensors so here
minus 1 means fill this dimension as
needed so so so this basically says
change the shape I believe that this
flattens the tensor into let's see I I
believe in this case that this is
flattening the tensor into one long
light like an X by 1 tensor and then
here there's a fully connected and
relatively connected umbrella and fully
connected layer at the end so as I said
before torches dynamically-typed like
some like if you're using tensor flow
you'd cut and compile the model and then
you'd run it and you can't change it in
pi torch if you want to you can actually
go in and change some of these lately
and like you could run a pass with this
network and then you could actually go
in and add like a plus 2 in here and the
next time the network runs it would
actually like add to so dynamic typing
lets you do interesting things like that
lets you get in a little bit of trouble
but not too much trouble so loss
function optimizer cross entropy loss is
pretty standard for classification trace
of optimizer matters so experiment with
different learning rates typically so
the learning rate specifies how rapidly
the parameters are updated learning rate
on the order of point zero zero one is
pretty standard if your network explodes
we reduce your learning rate and this is
what training looks like this is pretty
boilerplate code so you're untrained for
certain number of epochs you actually
need to keep track of loss and stuff
yourself
so boilerplate code looks something like
this so you go through data in your
train loader you get your inputs to make
the images and labels from the data set
this is important actually this is kind
of a gotcha
so torch tensors have gradients
associated with them so when you're in
training mode and you evaluate the
network gradients are being saved and
this can do some weird things so I would
recommend sticking with this sort of
boilerplate code and using okay let's
see okay there's no about here but I
think we went over before there's this
eval mode and and so if you're at test
time you want to want to use evaluation
mode so you're not actually training
your model at test time so loss is this
criterion across entropy loss backwards
is interesting so this says update the
model weights based on the loss function
that you observed during training and
optimizer dot step okay and I think that
I I need to recall the difference
between last step backward and backwards
and optimizer step but together they
update the weights in the model and then
you can keep track of the running loss
and print the running loss over time so
that you can evaluate how well your
network is doing you can serialize your
model to disk often as a dot pi torch
file and then
if you evaluate the model on test data
you can say okay like you can look at
the predicted outputs
okay so this is just a one-hour
presentation I hope that I've covered
some of the most important points I
wanted to point to some additional we've
some of the best resources that I found
personally so pi torch org I've been you
know in and out of there throughout this
presentation and that has really great
documentation and tutorials also
anything that comes out of research is
pretty quickly reflected in the PI torch
light like on let it live like in the PI
torch documentation Stanford has a
really good course on cnn's and visual
recognition this is it's free it's
online their lecture notes syllabus
really useful they go in-depth into the
linear algebra of everything so that's
if you're looking for sort of like a one
semester long explanation I'd recommend
that and
it if you're interested in the details
of deep learning I'd recommend the deep
learning book by in good fellow good
fellow there's a couple of chapters on
computer vision as well so that's it for
my presentation thank you for listening
and if there are any questions I'd be
happy to take them
[Applause]
yes
three bills
what yeah very good question so the
question is hyper parameter tuning I'd
say for that I'm definitely a deep
learning book by in Goodfellow like if
you want a really long answer it's very
long very accurate very to the point so
I'm gonna start with I'm gonna give two
answers so the first answer is kind of
specific to computer vision and it's
that like if you have an a picture of a
dog for example that's like you know
like it like a thousand pixels or
something
it's really like the features in a dog
are really complicated so if you want
good performance in practice on image
data you want to start by extracting
features with a CNN and then you get
maybe some get some like a feature
vector and then you go off.that so I
mean you maybe say okay a image that has
corners and vertical lines in these
places is a dog so now like so typically
with computer vision you want to start
it up you want to start hyper parameter
tuning at that point I'd say there's a
number of approaches probably probably
in practice for computer vision you want
to try different architectures so here
here like for classification there's a
bunch of backbones so I try a bunch of
different backbones benchmark the
performance see which backbone works
best you can also go into the backbones
and add layers or remove layers most of
the time if you make a model deeper
you'll improve the performance see what
else also
image augmentation for computer vision
is important so you know if you have an
image of a dog maybe you flip it
horizontally maybe you crop it and in
general image augmentations help avoid
overfitting and generally improve
performance so those would be some of
the first things that I look at
generally speaking training computer
vision models is expensive so if you're
training you know a small model on like
a small tensor you might have the luxury
of you know trying a million different
like hyper parameter settings for
computer vision on the data sets are
typically large so I think in practice
people tend to stick with you you know a
few core angles of like like adding
layers image augmentation different
different backbones is probably like if
you want to get good performance in
practice those are some of the most
promising directions yes
that's a really good question
so I don't know on CPU threads I do know
on GPU
so on GPU okay so here it says CPU so
here so on GPU this is running on CUDA
zero which means like the first GPU if
you have multiple GPUs you can say you
can set the device to CUDA : 1 and
that'll be the second GPU and so on and
so forth
that's for managing GPUs which is
typically where the bottleneck is for
for image processing I don't actually
know how torch handles CPU threading but
torches Python first so I think if you
wanted to run on multiple threads you
can look into multi processing III pry
shouldn't Google that not not not super
firm I I haven't worked with multiple
threads my experience at least is that
like they like at least when I run into
cost like there's a cost of actually
running the model so if you have a big
model you have a lot of cost in the
model and also if you have data on CPU
like typical GPUs like 8 gigs of memory
so a lot of times you have bottlenecks
between moving data from CPU to GPU and
that's like another potential bottleneck
but but very good question yes
mm-hmm
right so here good question
so I probably should have plotted the
bounding boxes so both the short answer
is both so you can see that this this
first bicycle is from pixel 160 to 170
across so that corresponds to this big
bicycle here and then there's two more
bicycle predictions here so those are
three and four and you can see that
these are overlapping so these are in
the 472 to 679 region so that's I
believe that that's this region here so
I think that there's two different
predictions for a bicycle in this region
and depending on the methods like our
CNN has different tricks in the loss
function to try and prevent duplicate
predictions of the same image but that
different models handle duplicate
prediction differently
yes
yeah
right that that's a very good question
and I think that really depends on the
task so there's two types of benchmarks
really one is the loss function or the
accuracy or whatever metric like the the
model spits out so like let's say you're
trying to predict like you have a
classification problem and you're trying
to predict whether an image is a dog so
one metric might be accuracy and say
like okay like this model is 80%
accurate and so the you know kind of
like the naive approach there is to you
know try different but if the metric you
care about most is accuracy the naive
approach is to try a bunch of different
models print out the accuracy of each
model and and select the model with the
highest accuracy that's kind of like
level zero accuracy is a metric that has
real-world meaning there are other
metrics like cross entropy that I was
talking about that doesn't make any
trouble for saying this but it doesn't
have much intuitive meaning you know if
you say the cross entropy of a model is
is this it did it doesn't mean much in
practice but it is really nice to
optimize over so so now for a
classification you could use mean
squared error but people have switched
over to cross entropy because it's
really nice rocked optimization but do
you I think it's really helpful to think
about what you're using the model for
like if you're using the model to
predict you know whether there's a car
in a parking spot but like think about
your use case like you know like how
much do you care about false positives
false negatives like what problem are
you trying to solve and maybe you say
okay I want to get a text message if
there's a car here and it's okay to have
a false positive but not a false
negative that sort of thing so I think
the best benchmarks are tied into the
like use case that the models being used
for
yep yes yes let's go here so for this
case so this is the training loss so
this is the cross entropy loss so so
lower is better so this is a good check
the model is getting better this doesn't
really mean much like you never like
people don't report you know like this
is more for internal use not not for
presentations not for that sort of thing
if the losses going down training is
working when the loss function
stabilized that's a good time to stop
training so here in terms of external
facing loss like these would be the
metrics that you might look at so I
apologize I skipped over this quickly in
the original presentation so here you
might say okay with torch no grab this
is a no this is similar to a vowel in
that it stops the computation of
gradients you go through the test images
that you haven't seen during training
you run the net on a series of test
images you let like in this case like
you know you get a bunch of output
predictions you take the the largest you
make a prediction with that label and
then here's where you're computing the
loss function you're saying okay does
the most likely prediction match the
label so here for this particular model
you might report something like a 55%
accuracy on the chesa and you might
break it down by image so this
particular classifier does really well
with ships but it doesn't do well with
cats does that answer your question
don't-don't-don't sure the training you
uh-huh I would say you know like I have
this model this model was trained on
this data set like here's the
performance of this model on the test
set the training metrics are useful for
debugging during training but I think
ultimately what matters is
generalization and that's on the test
set so test set metrics are ultimately
what matters and training says metrics
are just what gets either yes
yes really good question so okay so
let's get started so there's this thing
called sensor board it's made by Google
so fortunately Facebook and Google are
kind of but like I guess like they both
work on deep learning research so tensor
board is this tensorflow tool for
visualizing models and you can also use
it in pi torch so you might get
something like this is this okay I can't
run it but one common workflow is to
write your training data in a certain
log format and then you can load that
data into tensor board and tensor board
has really good support for
visualizations
let's see you trying to come up with an
example a training loss I know there's
an activation plot okay
okay so you might get something that
looks like this where you can look at
visualize weights and activations and
your network didn't does that answer
your question okay
any other questions
thanks Daniel
Brooks for leading us through your talk
on computer vision with pied scorch
everyone please give them another round
of applause
[Applause]